le chesnay-versailles remporte le choc
de cette sixième journée de nationale 2
le lcv 78 qui pointait à la 3e place du
classement avant la rencontre a dominé
le cinquième le stade français sur son
parquet au gymnase bel air le score 53 à
je pense que on gagne cette star parce
qu'on a bien joué en défense c'était un
match c'était un match important pour
nous parce que c'est un
c'était un derby et je pense qu'on
mérite ce essart 2
de gagner le match seul bémol la fin de
match du chesnay versailles à pouces 7 à
3 minutes 40 du terme les yvelinoises
ont pas réussi à conserver leur avance
et se sont fait peur jusqu'à la dernière
seconde on a perdu énormément de ballons
et ça bah ça peut coûter cher et on le
voit en fin de match on aurait pu le
tuer avec les lancers francs déjà mais
si on perd pas des ballons on leur donne
pas cette possibilité de revenir et ça
on n'a pas su faire
donc on aurait pu se rendre la tâche
plus facile sans les pertes de balle
au classement les joueuses de vinko
bardy qui réalise un début de saison
surprenant pour un promu avec cinq
victoires et une défaite
un bilan qui permet aux yvelinoise de
partager le fauteuil de leader avec
saint paul hervo
on s'attendait pas forcément à ça parce
que ce serait vraiment prétentieux note
pas en montant de nationale 3 on
assurait deux tout de suite dire bah on
a les capacités d'être au tableau nous
notre objectif c'est d'abord le maintien
on prend les clefs de les matches les
uns après les autres
après maintenant crache pas sur les
victoires on est à 5 1 on est très
content d'avoir gagné ce mur
le stade français qui sont
potentiellement des grosses équipes
autre point positif de cette soirée le
chesnay versailles reste invaincu à
domicile le gymnase bel air est devenue
une forteresse imprenable une cité
d'elle qu'il faudra à nouveau défendre
ce samedi 12 novembre à 20 heures les
yvelinoises reçoivent allant sonner
sixième du classement